je te dirai pourquoi tout nouveau
produit de samsung est sorti a très peu
de temps c'est ce modèle là c'est la
samsung galaxy tab s est plus c'est une
toute nouvelle tablette mais une toute
nouvelle tablette qui est d'un très haut
de gamme et qu'on pourrait si on
souhaite venir comparer faire une
analogie à l'ipad pro et notamment de
par son charisme
parce que oui si on laisse faire des
tablettes qui coûte cher qui coûte très
cher mais qui n'est peut-être pas fait
pour vous j'ai destiné à certains usages
alors certes plus on en a et plus on
pourra faire chose même si on souhaite
juste venir visionner des films et des
séries et bien pourquoi pas seulement
une fois de plus qu on garde ça en tête
dans un coin dante atteint on refera un
point à la fin de la vidéo de 949 euros
dont l idée aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
si cette samsung galaxy tab et 7 plus
est fait pour vous qu'est ce qu'elle
peut vous apporter comme un usage à quoi
elle va vous servir à 949 euros dans la
configuration la plus laide c'est
vraiment se fournir dégrossir essayer de
comprendre aujourd'hui et je compte sur
vous pour me dire en commentaire
évidemment ce que vous en pensez mais
juste avant juste avant que ce n'est pas
déjà fait vous invite à venir vous
abonner en quatre petits boutons rouges
que vous avez juste là pour tout savoir
de la tutelle parce qu'en plus j'ai
plein de choses à nous raconter alors si
vous avez ça me sort de ma sortie
il faut bien parce qu'il ya plein de
nouveautés on parle de ce smartphone là
le samsung galaxy z paul ii très très
prochainement par également d'un
smartphone plutôt entrée de gamme chez
samsung samsung galaxy à 21 aces ne vous
apparaître que moment ça va bientôt être
chose faite on pas également des
galaxies à 41 qu'il parle bien évidement
audio chez samsung avec les boys like
donc voyez ya plein de raconter plein
belle histoire donc pour tout savoir et
pour être tenu informé dès qu'une
nouvelle vidéo arrivera à boucler son
petit bouton rouge que vous avez juste
en dessous vous êtes tibia cloche comme
ça vous savez tout
bon déjà le design j'aime beaucoup on a
ici tout un dos qui est en aluminium
voyons là toute une partie envers par
contre la partie envers elle vous
servira uniquement pour me remettre
votre stylet et pour la recharge ne vous
en parle dans quelques instants on va se
rapprocher les petits boutons sont juste
là vous avez un bouton pour venir
l'allumé pour éteindre des petits
boutons de volume on va effectivement le
petit module photo et je vous en parle
en quelques instants également on va
leur charge est ici pour l'instant en
usb c'est on voit bien les différents on
parlera kg 1 2 3 4 des micros on en voit
ici on en voit également son côté on a
ici un capteur d'empreintes digitales
pour me garder verrouillé qui dérouille
extrêmement facilement ça c'est bien et
c'est très très pratique et on a une
tablette qui pèse 5 175 grammes de façon
un peu global moi j'aime bien le design
il respire vraiment la solidité il ya
très très belle finition fait de la part
de 500 ici on a un écran super amoled
4 pouces avec une résolution de 2800 par
1752 pixels à 266 pixels par pouce et
surtout un écran qui est un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz et ça
devient vraiment nous apporter de la
fluidité
lorsque vous venez naviguer et ça c'est
vraiment vraiment agréable alors sans
verre vous n'avez pas la voir surtout il
ya des jeux ou des applications qui vous
apporteront une expérience 100 verte
mais pour tous les autres vous allez
dire switcher parce qu'il ya un switch
intelligent pour éviter de consommer
davantage parce que oui effectivement le
sens inverse de ces cas ça consomme
davantage de batterie on également un
écran qui est optimisé pour lutter
contre la lumière bleue et avec une
gamme de couleurs ntsc et il est
compatible en plus agile hier 10 + moi
ce que j'aime bien sûr cet écran c'est
qu'effectivement de plus à me sont
maîtrise vraiment bien celle d'alain à
l'écran qui est vraiment parfaitement
bien maîtrisée point un peu négatif
c'est qu'il est très réfléchissants
quatre points qui est important ici
c'est l'expérience multimédia maintenant
un peu plus de son on a joué 10 et 4
haut parleurs un ici ici ici et ici ça
bien vous apporter de la spatialisation
est ce qui fait qu'on va très facilement
pouvoir entendre quelque chose qui se
situe juste ici ou juste ici en fonction
de ce que vous allez venir regarder et
écouter comme contenu donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment agréable et
se sont quand même dire qu'est ce qui se
passe là du bruit un peu loin dans ma
pièce par l'aïe en fait nan ça provenait
de ma tablette
il ya une vraie belle expérience de
spécialisation tout ça en plus avec du
dolby atmos quatre haut parleurs de 1,6
watt chacun pour être extrêmement précis
pour un peu négatif pour l'expérience
multimédia glace et que vous n'avez
absolument aucune prise jack nulle part
sur le très haut de gamme une fois de
plus ce n'est pas surprenant et c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui mais à côté de ça
pour y brancher un casque sans fil ou
alors pourquoi pas des petits bugs
notamment les samsung galaxy 2 live
parce que vous avez du bluetooth 5.0
côté performances on à ce qui se fait de
mieux alors c'est très intéressant parce
que je sais pas si vous vous intéressez
à ce que propose samsung on va revenir
quelques semaines en arrière lorsque je
vous ai présenté la nouvelle gamme note
gamme avec le stylet également mais sur
du smartphone samsung galaxy note 20
samsung galaxy note 20 ultra et dans les
deux cas dans pas presque le monde
entier sauf les us et le canada et bien
vous avez le processeur de samsung c'est
l'exynos 990 processeur très haut de
gamme et pour le canada et les us vous
avez un processeur de qualcomm c'est le
snapdragon 865 et ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'est toujours ce découpage
ans une notion de business il ya un deal
avec qualcomm qui fabrique le seul
dragon 1165 plus qu' aujourd'hui le
processeur de smartphone le plus
performant au monde
clairement de
tout le monde est devant celui de
samsung ce qui fait que lorsque vous
achetez un samsung galaxy note dans
notre vin ultra en europe
et bien vous allez avoir un processeur
qui va être moins performant que celui
des etats unis
et c'est extrêmement intéressant ce
modèle là et bien c'est qu'ils ont fait
le choix de mettre directement et dans
le monde entier instinct dragonne 865
plus autant dire que votre tablette
elle sera bien plus performante que le
smartphone le plus haut de gamme de
samsung en europe donc ça c'est assez
rigolo ce qui est bien en tout cas c'est
que ça apporte vraiment beaucoup de
performances même si je suis pas sûr
vous puissiez mesurer réellement la
différence qu'il faut vraiment venir le
pousser dans ses retranchements
enfin ça c'est le premier point et puis
le deuxième point bien évidemment c'est
une meilleure gestion de l'énergie
la machine équipée du processeur de
qualcomm consommera beaucoup moins
d'énergie et vous emmènera un peu plus
loin alors vous avez de config si giga
de ram 128 go de stockage 8 gigas de ram
256 go de stockage dans les deux cas
extensible grâce à une carte microsd
pour monter jusqu'à un terrain alors ici
je peux venir jouer à des jeux avec ma
tablette très facilement ses pratiques
parce qu'il ya un grand écran maintenant
le côté un peu négatif de l'histoire
c'est calais quand même un petit peu
lourde
et lorsque vous la tenez à bout de bras
pendant un moment voilà c'est pas simple
il ya des inconvénients siècle ce grand
écran
j'allais lâcher notamment un jeu comme
asphalt neuf ici c'est pas toujours très
très très simple ça demande de faire un
petit peu d'acrobaties mais bon on finit
par y arriver avec un peu d'exercice
pour regarder des films et des séries
sert aussi très bien mais je vous
conseille de venir la pause et parce que
s'ils voulaient garder la main et bien
arrivé un moment où foyer par écouter
une fois de plus un petit peu lourd et
pour venir lire votre journal au
quotidien et voir toutes les infos
qu'ils peuvent vous intéresser
moi je trouve ça vachement bien c'est
très lisible un grand écran et là dessus
on a vraiment un très très bon confort
de lecture et autre point qui est
intéressant c'est au niveau de
l'autonomie alors d'une très grosse
batterie de 10,90 milliampères heures
why not ça marche ça va très très bien
maintenant il ya un truc que je regrette
un petit peu et je trouve que samsung
aurait pu aller beaucoup plus loin là
dessus surtout une fois de plus sur un
produit qui toute la petite somme de 949
euros dans la version de base est bien
écouter ce que je regrette vraiment
c'est le bloc de charges puisqu'ici on
nous met un bloc de chasse de 15 watts
voilà et ça c'est un petit peu dommage
parce que vous dégagez une batterie de
10 milles 90 millions tandis que ça va
mettre du temps et qu'en plus on vous
dit il et compatit avec une charge de 45
watts
pourquoi pour un tarif comme celui là ne
pas nous mettre directement le bloc de
charges de 45 watts surtout qui coûte la
petite somme gelée de thé juste là de 49
euros
alors je sais il ya des barges à
préserver bon mais malgré tout ça quand
même relativement dommage surtout
qu'avec votre bloc de 15 watts vous
aller recharger deux
zéro à cent pour cent en trois heures
autant vous dire qu'il faut vraiment
vous enlevez patience a contrario avec
lui 45 watts vous avez changé de 0 à
100% en 90 minutes
j'en ai une très grosse batterie fois de
plus n'oubliez pas de 10000 90 meilleurs
terreur donc autant de recharger toutes
les cellules dont il faut un certain
temps côté logiciel on tourne ici sur
auron annuel 2.5 alors ouais je sais pas
si vous connaissez c'est vraiment très
très bien j'en ai déjà beaucoup parlé au
niveau des smartphones et on retrouve
également ici au niveau de sa tablette
ça marche extrêmement bien vous avez un
accès très rapide à vos paramètres tout
est extrêmement bien classés tous à
baser sur un android disent rien de bien
neuf là dessus tous qui est vraiment
intéressant sur la tablette et bien
c'est fait pour activer le decs et
d'utiliser votre tablette comme un petit
ordinateur ça c'est complètement
optimisé si on avait un clavier qui si
on n'a pas besoin retrouver vos
différentes applications pour lé lancé
et ça vient d'ouvrir les fenêtres comme
sur un pc pouvaient faire du multi
fenêtres déplacés m comme vous le
souhaitez enfin à côté qui est
extrêmement pratique et pour la petite
productivité ça fonctionnerait bien
autre point intéressant que vous avez
deux petites caméras l'arrière alors ses
deux caméras l'arrière on pourrait dire
l'effective mans sur une tablette en
utilisant a nécessairement effectivement
on l'utilisera beaucoup moins qu'avec
son smartphone
quoique encore il ya certaines personnes
qui vont peut-être les utiliser beaucoup
mais comme on est dans l'idée de la
productivité on va utiliser ses caméras
pour se dire tiens je vois ça ça
m'intéresse pas je prends en photo je
prends mon style et mon respect ne vient
griffonné dessus pour venir à noter et
venir perfectionner des idées on est
vraiment faire plus dans l'idée de la
création dans ce processus là et c'est
vraiment ce conteneur faire plus avec
ses caméras plus que des photos
souvenirs pour la famille parce
qu'effectivement on met rarement une
grosse tablette comme ça dans son sac à
main ou dans son sac à dos puisque
premier à dégainer rapidement soit
toujours extrêmement évidence à ses
premiers points
et puis deuxième fois comme vous avez
beaucoup de performance derrière ce avec
toutes les applications liées à la
réalité augmentée alors je sais
aujourd'hui on est la réalité augmentée
il ya certaines applications qu'on peut
avoir et on peut facilement supporter
plus facilement avec un grand écran
qu'avec un petit écran de smartphone
c'est vrai mais malgré tout c'est
quelque chose qui se développe de plus
en plus et vous avez cas par exemple
prendre l'idée d'ikea vous avez
l'application vous pré positionner vos
meubles très facilement en virtuel en
réalité augmentée pour on va pas avoir
effectivement deux caméras qui nous en
dira beaucoup pour revenir à faire des
souvenirs mais pour une fois de plus le
côté productivité c'est un réel sens la
caméra à l'avant par contre elle va
remplir vraiment sa fonction et encore
plus en ce moment pour venir collaborer
le fait qu'elle soit positionné juste au
centre là c'est vraiment extrêmement mal
hein ça vous permettra de faire à des
conférences j'en sais rien moi sur zoom
sur tout ce que vous voulez très
facilement surtout pour le télétravail
et vous le savez en ce moment
vraiment besoin donc la position est
vraiment idéal une ak duquel son cousin
c'est correct
en tout cas les satisfaisante côté photo
samsung propose un combo avec deux
capteurs ici un premier 13 mégapixels
couverture de f 2.0 c'est un capteur
grand temps que c'est un grand classique
mais vous avez un ultra grand-angle
c'est un 5 mégapixels avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés est qui ouvre à f
2.2 pouvait venir filmer en 4k jusqu'à
30 images par seconde tandis qu'à
l'avant et planck est juste ici vous
avez une petite caméra de cette fille de
8 mégapixels couvre f 2.0
cette tablette dans le très haut de
gamme à une fonctionnalité qui est
extrêmement intéressante est rendu
possible grâce à ce style et alan le
stylet chez samsung s'appelle le spd le
espagne permet de faire plein de choses
dessinée griffonné faire des croquis
prend des idées pouvaient venir
travailler aussi avec collaborer écrit
renvoyer ou juste venir remplacer votre
doit donc il doit remplir de multiples
fonctions le fait extrêmement bien est
ce qui est vraiment intéressant avec
celui là s'ils voulaient que je sais pas
si vous avez suivi ce qu'est sorti une
fois de plus du côté de la gamme note ya
pas longtemps
samsung galaxy note 20 samsung galaxy ne
devaient-ils traille avait une
différence en termes de latence alors la
latence une fois de plus c'est
l'intervalle entre le moment où vous
prenez vous posez vous écrivez est ce
qui va s'afficher à l'écran plus votre
latence est faible et plus le retour
sera réaliste comme ce que vous allez
pouvoir retrouver notamment avec un
crayon sur un bout de papier avec le
samsung galaxy note 10 de l'année
dernière vous avez une latence de 40 2
millisecondes avec le galaxy note 20
ondes et de latence de 26 secondes
c'était déjà beaucoup mieux mais avec le
samsung galaxy note valtra onu latence
de neuf millisecondes pour vraiment dire
maximiser l'expérience d'écriture et
c'est ça qu'on va retrouver dans cette
samsung galaxy tab et cèdent plus le nom
à rallonge et bien c'est une expérience
complètement maximiser pour ni à
griffonner dessiner faire des croquis de
la retouche tout ce que vous voulez on
est donc dans le très haut de gamme de
ce que sait faire samsung grâce à ce
style est bien évidemment tous en
partenariat avec quoi comme autant vous
dire que ça marche des samares très très
bien il ya un truc à savoir qui est pas
extrêmement pratique c'est que pour
venir recharger dernier vous avez cette
petite partie là vous venez vous le
posez c'est aimante et hop la voilà sur
le devant vous avez le voyant avec votre
niveau de batterie mais vous vous direz
que lorsque vous êtes posé sur une table
et bien ça va venir bouger un petit peu
vous avez raison donc du coup on peut
venir aussi le poser eh bien écoutez ici
sur le dessus c'était monté c'est très
bien c'est robuste ça ne bouge
absolument pas mais par contre ça n'a
pas venir charger bon bah c'est un point
de détail
il faut le savoir vous allez pouvoir
venir utiliser votre stylet écran est un
pur laissé de très jolis messages et
voyez pas plus l'écriture est magnifique
si le monsieur greu effacé en appuyant
sur le
ton faire vos plus belles oeuvres d'art
voyez pouvait faire des choses très
sympathique c'est très cool avoir une
liste de courses
bon moi voyez j'écris très très très mal
vous retrouverez bien évidemment tous
vos réactions notamment pour faire des
captures d'écran et ensuite pouvoir
venir griffonné dessus extrêmement
facilement donc ça aussi c'est très bien
vous avez accès à toutes vos apithy
créer une note affichée les notes
sélection intelligente les captures les
messages animer les airs doodle la trad
enfin ya beaucoup de possibilités avec
le stylet ça vous en ai déjà parlé pour
la gamme notes et surtout après et bien
vous pouvez venir à l'enregistrer au
format word au format powerpoint vous
pouvez enregistrer dans samsung note
c'est ça c'est un truc est vachement
intéressant parce que vous pouvez
commencer à griffonner ici office vous
reprenez la main dans votre samsung
galaxy note banques devaient l'ultra et
vous pouvez revenir ici après travailler
puisque tout va venir sont synchronisées
directement dans le cloud on a une
tablette qui bénéficie des dernières
technologies notamment le wifi 6 on s'en
doutera là dessus on n'a pas de nfc on
n'a pas nécessairement le besoin alors
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous au
bar en commentaire il existe différentes
versions la version que j'ai ici c'est
une version wifi c'est un point qui me
semblera le plus juste acheté il existe
une version 5 g de pouvoir insérer une
carte sim pour avoir de la data partout
dans la rue ça coûte plus cher pour ce
que c'est ce que je vous conseillerais à
ce moment là c'est faire du partage de
connexion avec votre smartphone ça
coûtera beaucoup moins cher et ça me
semble donc avoir plus de chance car
dites moi ce que vous pensez de ça en
bas en commentaire comme on n'a pas de
carte sim on a un d'astro et membre de
0,500 45 watts par kilogramme et c'est
une tablette existe en 3 alors le modèle
que j'ai là à moi c'est ce qu'on appelle
le mystic silver il existe également en
mystique blacks tout noir ou alors en
mystique bronze notamment les couleurs
qu'on a beaucoup vu au niveau de la
nouvelle gamme note et c'est un produit
comme je vous le disais qu'ils coûtent
en version wi fi et 100 m qui génère du
stockage 949 l'euro que vous pouvez
trouver en 246 giga de stockage à 1029
europass les 1000 euros
c'est quand même relativement cher et
après il ya un autre usage qui est
extrêmement intéressant mais ce n'est
pas le produit en test donc je vais pas
vous en parler tout de suite sa nouvelle
cover que vous avez avec cette cover
avait effectivement vous le protégez
vous avez une petite partie pour venir
poser votre stylet qui se recharge
facilement ça c'est bien mais vous avez
également un clavier ce qui permet
d'aller plus loin au niveau des usages
avec le decs pour vraiment venir
l'utiliser comme un petit ordinateur on
est un peu dans l'idée de ce qu'on
retrouve goûter de chez qualcomm avec
les all white and always connected pc
qui tourne sur le snapdragon
sauf que là vous avez à sa dragonne 805
plus
et extrêmement puissants extrêmement
performant on n'ira pas aussi loin que
si vous avez un processeur intel core i7
ou ainsi neuf bien évidemment va pas
aller faire du gros montage vidéo et
choses comme ça de chine et par contre
pour aller loin en termes de
productivité familiale aux mêmes
professionnels ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et mais pour travailler avec
son espèce eh bien ça vous ouvre plein
d'usagé cette cover qui bordent coup
quand même un certain prix 229 euros et
je voulais dit le bloc de charges 45
watts 49 euros même si des fois vous
pouvez trouver un petit peu moins cher
donc ce qui fait que si vous voulez
cette machine la plus le clavier plus le
bloc de charges 45 watts et bien vous
êtes un quasiment 1300 euros et tout de
suite ça coûte extrêmement cher c'est
pour ça que pose vraiment la question je
vous dis
réfléchissez est ce que cette samsung
galaxy ace est plus est fait pour vous
alors effectivement extrêmement
alléchant
est ce que le fait de mettre autant
d'argent va justifier l'usagé que vous
en avoir derrière c'est vraiment la
question à vous poser pour moi c'est
vraiment une tablette qui va se destiner
aux créatifs vraiment pour un côté un
peu plus professionnel
si vous voulez dessinée facilement si
vous êtes illustrateur si vous êtes
infographie si vous avez besoin d'une
tablette pour pouvoir tout le temps noté
vos idées pour griffonner pour dessiner
par tout ce que vous voulez si vous
voulez faire de la retouche avec
suffisamment de performance et que le s
pen est extrêmement important pour vous
avec cette faible latence et bien je
pense que ça peut être intéressant si
maintenant le fait d'avoir un style et
c'est un petit peu gadget et que ça vous
intéresse pas nécessairement et si vous
voulez un stylet mais que les 9000
secondes vous vous en fichez vous
trouverez des tablettes moins cher au
catalogue de samsung avec un style ça il
faut vraiment savoir si maintenant le
style vous intéresse absolument pas mais
vous voulez un bel écran et bien les
jeter un coup d'oeil du côté de la gamme
de samsung
mais une fois de plus est ce que vous
avez vraiment les usages pour venir
mettre cette somme là aujourd'hui en
cette machine regardez donc vous ce que
vous en pensez
hambach commentaire est ce que vous
pourriez aller sur ce produit pour ces
usages est ce qu'au contraire vous vous
dites mans non non non j'ai pas besoin
de ça pas pour ces usages c'est très
cher pour ce que je vais en faire ou
alors à contre a eu ce qu'on me dit ok
effectivement ça c'est fait pour moi le
fait d'avoir c'est très faible latence
ça correspond à mes usages correspondait
besoin et ça justifie complètement mark
et moi ça en bas en commentaire de leur
trouve extrêmement rapidement vous
l'avez compris parce que on a plein de
choses à regarder du côté de chez
samsung plein de produits très cool
donc ça c'est vachement bien samsung et
plein d'autres sur ce je vous embrasse
ce baron beaucoup d'amour et à très vite
chaos
cela place